c'est les sénateurs bonjour donc comme
la présidente le disait nous avons
proposé au gouvernement un rapport dans
lequel nous avons détaillé la méthode
pour mettre en place cette concertation
nationale sur le système énergétique de
demain au cœur de cette méthode il y
avait les liens très étroits entre
démocratie participative et démocratie
représentative c'est-à-dire le fait que
cette concertation devait se rattacher
au débat parlementaire qui est souvent
dans le domaine de
dans le cas qui nous occupe dans le
domaine de l'énergie et donc nous avons
proposé une méthode qui mettait un
dialogue c'est de forme de démocratie ce
qu'on fait souvent à la CNP parce que
nous considérons qu'il est très
important d'articuler c'est de forme de
démocratie qu'il y en a une qui était
très à apprendre des décisions c'est la
démocratie bien évidemment
représentative donc c'est pourquoi nous
avons proposé au gouvernement ont tout
d'abord un certain nombre de thèmes de
sujets trois en particulier le sujet de
la consommation vous voulez se briété
mais pas seulement le sujet de la
production donc le mix énergétique les
électrique et le sujet de la gouvernance
et des coûts donc trois grands sujets
autour de quelle la concertation devait
s'articuler avec deux grands volets
envolés maxi public c'est-à-dire
vraiment un tour de France des
territoires notamment des régions parce
que la question énergétique ne se
décline pas que ce soit en termes de
consommation de production pareil dans
toutes les régions françaises et une un
moment un peu plus délibératif avec ce
que nous avons appelé un forum des
jeunesse avec environ de ce de son jeune
tiré au sort âgé de 18 à 35 ans pour
travailler vraiment sur des volets
particuliers de l'alpec la loi énergie
et climat tout ça pour nourrir non
seulement le projet de la gouvernement
mais d'abord et surtout le débat
parlementaire et c'était très important
que ça vienne en amont parce que comme
je le disais tout à l'heure c'est les
parlementaires qui vont pouvoir et
devoir se positionner et voter donc ils
seront éclairés de tout un tas
d'éléments parmi lesquels là on va dire
l'expertise citoyenne ou là où la voix
des de celles et ceux qui auront
participé ça nous paraît un élément
d'éclairage essentiel pour le vote et ce
qui est important aussi c'est que la
première ministre vient de nous
missionner comme garant de la
concertation donc nous n'avons pas
seulement élaboré la méthode de cette
concertation nous allons aussi la
garantir au sens que nous verrons à la
transparence la transparence de la
méthode et la manière dont elle va se
mettre en place la manière dont les
réunions vont se passer et aussi la
manière dont ce forum des jeunesse va se
mettre en place une autre élément de
cette garantie c'est le fixe c'est nous
qui allons restituer ce qui se disent
qu'il y a un élément très important la
démocratie participative et en fait quoi
le fait d'inviter nos concitoyens
s'exprimer donc on manie la parole de
celles et ceux qui s'expriment cette
donnée qui ont donné qualitative elle a
quand même difficile à manier dans le
sens où elle peut être des forts
orientaux orientés donc elle nécessite
un traitement neutre transparent et
exhaustif donc c'est pourquoi le
gouvernement a considéré opportun de
nous confier aussi cette tâche de
rédiger le compte-rendu de ce Tour de
France des régions mais aussi du travail
des forums des jeunesse et dans la
lettre des missions de la première
ministre et les précisé aussi que c'est
notre rapport qui devrait éclairer les
travaux de l'axe transmission
énergétique de CNR qui a été mis en
place par le gouvernement donc un rôle
important qui a été donné à la garantie
de la CNP dans cette mission voilà
[Musique]